there are a few cities in the world
whose history is as long and storied as
Istanbul's for a period it was the most
important city in the world laying at
the crossroads between East and West it
sat at the heart of two empires and was
coveted by many others it's a city that
has gone by many names
Byzantium Zagreb Mik Lagarde and perhaps
the most famous of all Constantinople
but when did this change occur when did
Constantinople become Istanbul to begin
Istanbul is old really old in fact it
was the city founded by Greek settlers
in the 7th century BC in its first name
was Basanti on his antium when latinized
it had numerous names to the Romans but
didn't enter the spotlights until some
small time Roman Emperor Constantine the
Great came along and the city he chose
was Byzantium although his first choice
was surgical what's now called Sofia and
he profound a Byzantium is the city of
Constantinople over the next thousand
years or so the city kept its name but
some citizens of the Roman Empire did
often refer to the city is Byzantium or
simply as he police which means the city
and those outside of the empire in the
arabic-speaking world knew the city is
Constantine ear now it shouldn't shock
you to know that the next change to the
name of Constantinople occurred after
the Ottoman conquest of the city in 1453
this was when the city's name became a
bit more vague with official documents
often opting for Constantine II aware as
many within the empire gave it the name
Easton pulley contraction of the Greek
phrase to the city this status of the
city having both a popular and an
official name continued into the 19th
century this was when Istanbul an
evolution of Eastern pulley began to see
more formal use and was even included in
the 1876 Ottoman Constitution it wasn't
until the end of World War 1 and the
collapse of the Ottoman Empire that the
former name of Constantinople changed
Mustafa Kemal the first president of the
New Republic of Turkey wanted to draw a
line between the old order and the new
and he did this in 1923 by formally
changing the name of Constantinople to
Istanbul to match what it was already
called by the Turkish people and he
asked that all of the nations respect
this change and start calling the
Turkish capital Istanbul from then on
they did not most major European nations
kept calling at what they had done
previously in of the world's major
powers it was only the United States
that acknowledged the change and so the
Turkish now had some difficulty since
they wanted to be taken seriously and so
to force the issue in 1930 Turkey passed
a new postal law which forbid the postal
service from delivering letters
addressed to Constantinople and this
worked which
is why most nations officially refer to
the city as Istanbul now except for the
Greeks I hope you enjoyed this episode
and the special thanks to all my patreon
supporters James vis Annette
Marvin casts out a man of culture Kelly
moneymaker
Danny Meloni Jon viscous Rob Waterhouse
mo Aaron the white James Castaneda
Gustav Swan Jordan long ray Marcus Ozma
spinning three plates cooling Castleman
filled oink oink Rashid Ali David
Silverman easy Maggie packs Kowski
Spencer Lightfoot of Winston K word
Robert Wetzel Lexy Schwinn Anthony
Beckett and Skye Chappell personally I
prefer Mick Lagarde